salut romain romain
romain alors un été où là désolé je suis
en retard j'avais embauché le médecin ok
mais pas un autre aura pour l'heure nous
j'avais rendez vous à 11h ah ok mais
quand même un rongeur hier à [ __ ] et
des temps d oullins du coup tu vas rire
quand je sais pas j'ai pas encore passé
à demain oui voilà
[Applaudissements]
pour vous connaissez le truc parker vous
avez rendez vous chez le médecin à 17h30
vous vous dépêcher pour pas être en
retard
vous arrivez vous vous posez dans la
salle d'attenté et elle est blanc bec et
il est 17h 25 puis les 17h30 et 17h45
18h 18h30 et tout le monde passe avant
ou alors c'est pas un complot des
illuminati dirigée contre votre personne
1 si ceux qui sont arrivés après vous
ils passent avant vous c'est parce
qu'ils connaissent le truc hein isaf qui
a toujours du retard dont ils ont
anticipé du coup bah il vous reste plus
qu'à être patient mais pourquoi est ce
que les médecins ont toujours une heure
de retard
vraiment alors d'abord disclaimer ont
dit les médecins mais moi j'ai été
infirmier libéral et je veux pas mentir
j'étais en retard aussi à peu près pour
les mêmes raisons que les médecins bon
ceci étant dit on va se pencher sur le
pourquoi
en gros voilà comment ça se passe quand
vous prenez rendez-vous chez le médecin
il vous donne un horaire et pour définir
cet horaire il a calculé la durée
moyenne d'une consultation 10 15 20
minutes selon les médecins et il
enchaîne les rendez vous toutes les 10
15 ou 20 minutes
mais autant chez le kiné par exemple on
peut estimer qu'il ya une durée
relativement fixes pour les séances
par contre un rendez vous chez le
médecin parfois ça prend plus de temps
que prévu
alors vous allez me dire pourquoi eh ben
on va passer en revue les six raisons
qui peuvent faire durer un rendez vous
chez m 1 le cas est plus grave que prévu
genre le patient il vient pour un simple
mal de tête et quand le médecin ausculte
il se rend compte qu'il a 20 de tension
ou alors il vient parce qu'il est
essoufflé et finalement il s'avère qu'il
est en train de faire un infarctus du
myocarde ou une embolie pulmonaire
et ils font le spécialisés parfois c'est
même des trucs moins graves mais qui
allonge la durée de la consultation de
le patient aura pas un mais plusieurs
problèmes
bah oui des fois on vient parce qu'on
tousse mais on en profite pour parler de
ces troubles du sommeil du mollet qui
fait un peu mal quand on marche on
demande une ordonnance pour des
médicaments et le certificat médical
pour le sport et cetera et puis les
personnes âgées par exemple elles ont
souvent plusieurs maladies à gérer ça
prend du temps
troisième cas le patient mais
venu tout seul il a une bronchite mais
ah bah tiens tant que vous y êtes
docteur il ya matifie là elle a mal au
ventre vous pouvez jeter un oeil alors
des fois le médecin il refuse et idy
banon vous reprenez un rendez vous plus
tard mais des fois il n'est ce pas une
petite fille à voir dans le monde donc
il perd du temps quatrièmement le
patient ne va pas bien du tout mais oui
le médecin ça peut être la seule
personne à qui on peut se confier
donc quand il ya un patient qui commence
à raconter ses problèmes à dire qu'il a
des soucis perso des troubles
psychologiques qui peuvent parfois être
graves
c'est compliqué de lui dire oui mon sens
cela ne leur est dépassé ça dégage 5
le médecin a une mauvaise nouvelle à
annoncer une maladie grave pareil même
chose que pour le cas précédent c'est
pas possible de dire voilà donc vous
avez un cancer ça fera 25 euros je ne
fais pas créé dominant dans ces cas là
il faut prendre le temps l'important est
que c'est inhumain sixième et dernier
cas il faut expliquer des choses
compliquées
bah oui il ya des maladies qui sont pas
évidentes à comprendre surtout comme ça
du premier coup parfois c'est les
traitements qui sont complexes et
souvent c'est les deux et c'est le rôle
du médecin de bien expliquer tout ça à
sensation dans un même ordre d'idée des
fois il faut donner des conseils
d'hygiène de vie faire de la prévention
et tout ça c'est pas forcément facile à
prévoir à la manche parce qu'être
médecin est comme une boîte de chocolats
voilà ça c'est pour les gens qui avaient
rendez-vous mais dont les consultations
dure plus longtemps que prévu
mais il ya aussi les urgences celles qui
sont pas assez grave pour aller aux
urgences de l'hôpital mais qui peuvent
pas attendre le prochain rendez-vous
disponible en général soit le médecin
les reçoit entre deux rendez vous mais
du coup ça décale les suivants soit il a
prévu un horaire exprès dans la journée
mais si on a deux ou trois ça décale
quand même faut savoir aussi qu'il ya
plein de médecins qui travaillent pas
uniquement dans leur cabinet ils peuvent
aussi faire des visites à domicile
travailler dans un hôpital dans une
clinique dans un centre de soins et
c'est le genre d'endroit où l'on peut
facilement prendre du retard
avant même d'arriver pour commencer ses
consultations bref vous voyez qu'il ya
plein de situations qui peuvent causer
des retards qui vont s'accumuler et du
coup on arrive facilement à une heure
parce que une heure s'est jamais que si
petit retard de 10 minutes
de cinq minutes 60 vous allez me dire le
médecin il a qu'à prévoir 30 minutes par
patient comme ça quand c'est plus simple
il gagne un quart d'heure et ça rattrape
les cas où c'est plus compliqué bah oui
mais non parce que hein
il ya beaucoup de patients 2 ya pas
beaucoup de médecins surtout dans
certains coins des rendez-vous deux fois
plus long ça veut dire deux fois moindre
rendez-vous par jour
donc quand vous appelez au lieu d'avoir
un rendez vous dans quatre jours vous en
avait un dans huit jours et on est
d'accord que souvent c'est compliqué
d'attendre aussi longtemps et encore là
on parle là rendez vous chez un
généraliste
parce que chez un ophtalmo ou un dermato
alors bien sûr il ya aussi la
possibilité d'expédier la consultation
plus vite possible ça ça veut dire
négliger l'aspect psychologique
1 ça veut dire pas poser trop de
questions pour savoir s'il n'y a pas un
truc un petit peu plus grave qu'il y
paraît ça veut dire devenir une machine
à prescrire des médicaments et ça veut
dire évacués l'aspect humain et
franchement quand on est dans la salle
d'attenté
on a envie que ça aille plus vite c'est
vrai mais quand on est dans le calumet
et que ces deux notes santé qu'il s'agit
là on a bien envie que le médecin y
prennent le temps qu'il faut non alors
ok ok il ya aussi parfois un problème
d'organisation
c'est pour ça qu'il ya certains médecins
car les vaches ignore à peu près dans
les temps
alors qu'il y en a d'autres ou plutôt
deux heures qu'une heure de retard c'est
vrai mais est ce que vous connaissez la
loi de hochstatt heures en gros ça dit
que vous pouvez planifier autant que
vous voulez c'est impossible de prévoir
précisément le temps que va prendre une
tâche complexe et la médecine
c'est complexe du coup à moins de revoir
l'organisation globale du système de
santé et des consultations c'est un
problème qui va être difficile à régler
sans perdre en qualité de sous alors je
vous vois venir vous allez peut-être
tenter d'arriver plus tard que l'heure
prévue l'histoire ne pas attendre ne
fait pas ça le jour où vous le ferez le
médecin sera à l'heure ça c'est la loi
de murphy
alors avant de vous laisser filer 2-3
conseil si vous avez besoin de voir le
médecin d'abord si vous pouvez vous
déplacer fait le salut prendra moins de
temps qu une visite à domicile
ensuite amener tous les documents dont
le médecin pourrait avoir besoin vos
ordonnances avec votre traitement
habituel si vous en prenez un vos
résultats
la lettre du médecin qui vous envoie si
vous allez voir un spécialiste et c'est
ça c'est pour éviter de faire perdre du
temps à tout le monde mais si vous
voulez attendre le moins possible prenez
rendez vous en début de journée quand le
retard s'est pas encore accumulé et puis
prévoyez de quoi faire passer le temps
dans la salle d'attenté
apportez votre ordinateur ou votre
tablette pour bosser ou pour mater une
série amenez votre console portable il
prévoyait de la lecture mais parce qu'on
n'est pas tous femmes des vieux femme
actuelle de septembre 2007 du chasseur
français
bref prenez de quoi vous empêcher
d'avoir le nez collé à l'horloge comme
ça que le temps passe plus lentement on
savait voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui si vous avez d'autres
questions de ce genre n'hésitez pas à me
les envoyer à question dtc @ gmail point
com on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là mettez vous
bien et surtout porteuse
[Applaudissements]